Imaginez la scène :
vous demandez l’heure à un ami,
et il vous répond :
« Il fait vingt degrés ».
Vous allez vous dire
qu’il a mal entendu votre question,
donc vous allez la répéter.
Mais imaginez qu’il insiste ;
qu’il vous réponde encore
« Il fait vingt degrés ».
Cette fois-ci,
vous allez vous dire
qu’il a un problème,
et vous allez peut-être
vous énerver.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que votre ami est
HORS-SUJET.
Qu’est-ce que
le HORS-SUJET ?
Eh bien c’est quand
vous répondez à côté.
On vous demande de réfléchir
à un problème A,
mais vous,
vous réfléchissez à un problème B.
Par exemple,
si je vous demande
si la démocratie
est le meilleur régime politique,
et que vous me répondez
que l’argent ne rend pas heureux,
là vous êtes hors-sujet
— TRÈS GROSSIÈREMENT
hors-sujet,
même.
Dans la pratique,
ce n’est pas binaire comme ça
— vous n’êtes pas soit
DANS le sujet,
soit HORS du sujet.
Les éléments de réponse
que vous apportez
dans votre dissertation
sont PLUS OU MOINS
pertinents.
Donc vous pouvez être
20 %
hors-sujet,
ou 70 %
par exemple.
Imaginez une jauge de pertinence :
vous devez être
LE PLUS
à droite possible.
Ça sera plus facile
avec les trois astuces
que je vais vous donner
dans cette vidéo,
mais vous avez D’ABORD
besoin d’une méthodologie
SOLIDE.
Ça tombe bien :
j’ai ce qu’il vous faut !
Inscrivez-vous à mon cours gratuit
de méthodologie de la dissertation,
soit en cliquant sur le lien
qui apparaît maintenant
en haut à droite de la vidéo,
soit en cliquant sur celui
qui est dans la description
de cette vidéo.
C’est un cours par e-mail
SIMPLE
et PRATIQUE
pour gagner RAPIDEMENT
des points
en dissertation.
Et en particulier,
mon cours réduit le risque
que vous commetiez un hors-sujet.
MAIS les trois astuces
que je vais vous révéler
ne sont pas dans ce cours.
Regardez donc ATTENTIVEMENT
cette vidéo jusqu’au bout,
et contrairement à tous les autres candidats,
vous,
vous serez IMMUNISÉS
contre le hors-sujet.
Quelle est LA MEILLEURE
garantie,
lorsque vous traversez la route,
de ne pas vous faire renverser ?
Alors oui,
mieux vaut traverser au vert
— mais bon en France…
la discipline,
c’est pas dans notre ADN.
Non,
la MEILLEURE
garantie
de ne pas se faire renverser,
c’est simplement
d’examiner soi-même la circulation,
pour savoir si la voie est libre.
Bon eh bien,
faites la même chose en dissertation :
lorsque vous analysez le sujet
après l’avoir découvert,
réfléchissez au risque du hors-sujet.
Demandez-vous s’il y a un piège,
si le libellé du sujet
semble vous induire en erreur.
Ça peut vous paraître BÊTE
comme astuce,
mais c’est en réalité
un filtre TRÈS PUISSANT.
En général,
les élèves qui commettent un hors-sujet
n’ont pas réfléchi à ce risque
lorsqu’ils ont commencé
à analyser le sujet.
Souvenez-vous donc
que lorsque vous analysez le sujet
au début de l’épreuve,
vous devez simplement
vous poser la question :
« Est-ce que je risque
de faire un hors-sujet ? ».
C’est tout simple,
mais c’est un réflexe
qui peut faire une ÉNORME
différence.
Je vous donne un exemple.
La seconde fois que j’ai passé
le concours de l’ENA
— c’était en 2014 —
le sujet de la dissertation
de culture générale était :
« La Résistance est-elle
un idéal du vingt-et-unième
siècle ? ».
Je me suis demandé
s’il y avait un risque de hors-sujet,